entre 2020 et 2021 117 journalistes ont
été tués du fait de leur profession des
crimes on l'a dit à l'instant qui sont
largement impunies dans la grande
majorité des cas bonjour Laurent Richard
merci d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes
journaliste réalisateur directeur de
forbidjan stories c'est un consortium de
journalistes que vous avez monté dont la
mission et de poursuivre et de publier
le travail d'autres journalistes qui
sont menacés emprisonnés ou assassinés
on en parlait à l'instant avec le cas
mexicain c'est un programme unique au
monde on va peut-être en rappeler la
jeunesse d'abord en fait l'idée elle est
toute simple donc on poursuivi on se
poursuit les enquêtes des reporters
assassinés menacés ou emprisonnés avec
une idée simple on est seulement
journaliste c'est d'utiliser le
journalisme pour défendre le journalisme
et faire en sorte que les gens aient
accès aux informations importantes et
quand on regarde de près pour quel type
d'enquête les journalistes sont
assassinés ils le sont parce qu'ils
enquêtent sur des crimes
environnementaux parce qu'ils ont 4 sur
des affaires de corruption importante de
blanchiment d'argent de violation des
droits de l'homme et donc nous notre
rôle c'est de poursuivre le travail et
en poursuivant le travail aussi dissuadé
ceux qui voudraient s'en prendre des
journalistes parce qu'ils peuvent
réaliser que ça sert à rien de tuer un
journaliste parce que l'histoire qui
voudrait passer sous silence finalement
va être exposé partout donc moi ça fait
des années ça fait 25 ans que je fais ce
métier de journalisme investigation et
en voyageant un peu partout dans le
monde et dans des pays où la liberté de
la presse n'était qu'une n'était qu'un
mot et pas du tout une réalité j'ai
aussi compris qu'on pouvait faire
bénéficier les autres de notre propre
liberté de la presse et que en tant que
journaliste français on pouvait
poursuivre le travail d'un autre
portrait donner et assurer un impact et
faire notre notre mission qui est
d'informer le grand public d'ailleurs il
faut le rappeler en 64% des meurtres de
journalistes sont pro de ce produit dans
des pays qui ne sont pas en conflit
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
la première de vos enquêtes
retentissantes à repris le travail de la
journaliste maltaise Daphné Galicia qui
a été assassinée en 2018 à Malte est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer comment
est-ce que vous travaillez concrètement
on travaille en réseau aujourd'hui avec
formida story ils ont coordonne le
travail de 150 journalistes 60
organisations de presse on travaille
secrètement pendant des mois sur une
enquête on se répartit le travail et on
enquête à la fois sur le meurtre qui a
pu assassiner le journaliste mais
surtout sur la poursuite des enquêtes
donc c'est ce qu'on a commencé à faire
avec notre premier projet c'était le
projet Daphné on était avec 45
journalistes 18 organisations de presse
en France on travaille avec le monde et
Radio France par exemple aux États-Unis
on travaille aujourd'hui avec le
Washington Post au gardien pour
l'Angleterre donc on a un réseau de
journalistes avec chacun des spécialités
un peu différentes sur l'évasion fiscale
sur les homicides sur les crimes
environnementaux et à la fin des fins on
publie en même temps partout dans le
monde l'enquête que certains voulaient
censurer pour qu'elle soit encore plus
exposées et pour que les gens aient
accès à l'information au final le
dernier exemple en date est à la fois
dramatique et très parlant vous rentrez
tout juste de Colombie vous avez et vous
travaillez en ce moment sur le travail
dans la journaliste qui s'appelle
Raphaël Moreno qui était colombien qui a
été assassiné le 16 octobre dernier ce
qui est absolument dingue dans cette
histoire c'est que c'est lui qui vous
avait contacté avant son assassinat pour
vous confier son travail ce sachant
menacé oui c'est ce qu'on met en place
avec ce qu'on appelle le savebox Network
c'est-à-dire qu'on propose aux
journalistes qui sont les plus en danger
sur la planète de mettre à l'abri au fur
et à mesure les investiaires les
investigations sur lesquels ils
travaillent et s'ils se sentent menacé
de nous faire savoir qui mettent à
l'abri et pour nous ainsi de pouvoir
poursuivre leur travail et c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec Raphaël notre équipe
était en contact avec lui sur ces
dernières semaines et même dans les
dernières heures avant son meurtre et se
sentait de plus en plus menacé
travailler et vivait dans une région du
nord de la Colombie dans le département
de Cordoba qui est ultra dangereuse il
enquêtait sur des affaires de corruption
de blanchiment d'argent local et toucher
à des intérêts familiaux claniques
politiques très important et donc
Raphaël se sentant menacé à partager ces
informations dès qu'il a été assassiné
on est parti pour la Colombie mais on a
rassemblé non seulement des journalistes
colombiens pour coordonner ce travail là
mais aussi des journalistes
internationaux
sud-américains et autres pour faire en
sorte que le travail de Raphaël ne
disparaisse pas avec lui vous avez tué
le message mais vous ne tuerez pas le
message c'est ce que vous répétez
souvent on vous doit aussi la faire
Pegasus récemment qui était ce logiciel
espion israélien à utiliser par des
gouvernements dans le monde vous avez
aussi poursuivi récemment le travail
d'omahaddad qui lui est au marathip
c'est moi qui est emprisonné au Maroc
au maradies il a été condamné à 6 ans de
prison on a poursuivi ce travail et on a
publié les enquêtes que le Royaume du
Maroc ne voulait pas avoir publié
Pegasus a été aussi un projet très
important où là on a expliqué aussi on a
révélé un système d'espionnage massif
mis en place par des gouvernements qui
avaient pour point commun d'utiliser ce
logiciel le logiciel Pegasus vendu par
une société israélienne qui s'appelle
si on veut vous aider drop bien story on
le rappelle est une association à but
non lucrative qui fonctionne grâce à des
dons donc on peut tout le monde grâce à
vous grâce à ceux qui nous écoutent et
qui nous regardent aujourd'hui mais
effectivement si on veut nous aider on
peut faire se connaître la mission et
contribuer en allant sur le site de
formidable stories et en donnant merci
beaucoup ce matin sur ce plateau à
l'occasion donc de la journée
internationale de lutte contre
l'impunité des crimes commises contre
les journalistes on a une pensée bien
sûr pour nos collègues disparus de RFI
Ghislaine Dupont et Claude ver